the chief inspector of schools has
warned today that a large proportion of
children
are bored lonely and miserable the
closure of schools during the pandemic
has disrupted routines and deprived
young people
of social contact ministers today
announced an extra 79 million pounds to
support children's mental health but for
some
it won't come soon enough from the
beginning adele robinson's report
contains some detailed testimony about
mental health issues and suicidal
feelings
which some viewers might find
distressing i'd probably think about it
like 24 7 just
like kill yourself like just repeatedly
like it's just kind of always in my head
this is a teenager in crisis rachel's
just
14 years old it's almost like
when like you just like get bad news or
something
like your heart just drops and it's just
kind of
always like that like that's just the
norm lockdown's hit
hard she's tried to take her own life
twice since the pandemic began
we've changed her name and revoiced her
words
you have all the time in like the week
like the month multiple months to just
think about how much you just don't want
to be here
and how much you hate yourself a swimmer
with multiple trophies covered
restrictions
took it all away she's being seen by
children's mental health services or
cams
in the community but her family say
they've been told her case
isn't serious enough for therapy i don't
really know
what they're like what they need from
you to be
to like get help immediately how you can
be in such a deep crisis
and cams are just like oh yeah
like take a bath or something like
literally
oh yeah go take a bath do some colouring
like yeah i want to kill myself but
i'll do some colouring and it will help
me
i don't know like if i want to take my
life
i'm not going to think about doing some
colouring i've been told that she's
having the
mental health equivalent of a heart
attack but she's been admitted to
hospital and then discharged the next
day with a sticking cluster
her father's desperate and says therapy
could be at least
four or five months away ten months on
from when his daughter first
tried to take her own life it's
heartbreaking um
it's it's very stressful she still has a
lot trouble sleeping
so i'd be awake with her at night time
you know just so that she wouldn't do
anything and that was the advice that
cams gave us but
that's not sustainable for more than a
few days to be honest and then i did
that for weeks and
you can't live like that must be
terrifying it is terrifying
children's mental health services have
been underfunded and
overstretched for years the pandemics
deepening the cracks
we have a system that is never meant to
cope with the demand
we're leaving young people's mental
health needs to get to that very high
bar to get crisis
point before they get support so there
is inconsistency in terms of a kind of
postcode lottery
and struggles for young people to be
seen for their first referral
and also them waiting times to go before
beyond that
millions are being invested in services
nhs england say
they continue to support young people's
mental health and are expanding support
and finding new and innovative ways to
reach young people through digital
platforms
they're asking anyone who's worried that
they or someone they care for is in
crisis
contacts their 24 7 urgent mental health
crisis support
immediately sometimes i wake up thinking
it is a nightmare
and then you have it dawns on you that
it's actually this is actually real
rachel's father like others is looking
into private therapy something many
can't afford
but it's a system in crisis right now
and this
is a plea for help i literally
said to them like i am gonna kill myself
again i feel like i feel quite desperate
like i don't know how to say to them
more clearly
adele robinson sky news
and if you have been affected by any of
the issues that were raised in adele's
report just now
you can contact the samaritans by
calling 116
123 or emailing joe samaritans.org